I am always working on music I'm not
just gonna put it out just because
people are waiting like it's taking this
long I'm gonna make it worth it well the
long wait might be over because Rihanna
just said she wants to release an album
this year but admits the pressure to
make new music is toxic so I want to do
something that was special and new and
different and unique ree hasn't dropped
a new album since 2016's AMT
what are you willing to do
she didn't put out any new music between
2017 and last year when she released two
new songs for the movie Black Panther
wakanda forever one of which is
nominated for an Oscar for best original
song
[Music]
now in a new interview with British
Vogue Rihanna's opening up about why she
hasn't dropped an album since Auntie
which she calls her most brilliant body
of work yet there's this pressure that I
put on myself that if it's not better
than that then it's not even worth it
it's a lot of hard work the singer calls
the pressure toxic and admits that it's
not the right way to look at music music
is an outlet and a space to create and
you can create whatever it doesn't have
to even be on any scale it just has to
be something that feels good it could
just be a song that I like it literally
could be that simple but despite being
on a music break re-insists she's been
recording music the whole time which
Echoes what she's told E.T over the
years I'm always working on music I'm
always working on music and when I'm
ready to put it out in the way that I
feel fit is gonna come out and you're
not going to be disappointed when it
happens it's going to be worth it and
while ree may not have dropped a new
album in seven years she's busier than
ever launching her Cosmetics line Fenty
Beauty and her lingerie line Savage X
Fenty which are both billion dollar
Brands I see how women feel like they
can see themselves on the shelves and
even in sizes in my in my lingerie line
so with skin care we we're going to do
the same thing we want these these
products to work for all skin types oh
and let's not forget in May she welcomed
her first child with rapper ASAP Rocky
do you think this stage in your life is
going to inspire new music yes you're
still going to get music from me maybe a
lullaby I can send you an ASAP dropping
Demos in the studio oh my goodness not a
lullaby my fans would kill me they
waited this long for a lullaby and she
revealed she's pregnant with baby number
two while performing during Apple
music's Super Bowl halftime show but now
the Grammy winner says she's ready to
release a new album and she wants it to
be this year adding that it would be
ridiculous if she did it I just want to
have fun I just want to make music and
make videos
we're ready when you are re and in the
meantime we'll just be here playing your
greatest hits
[Music]